carlos es el administrador de un sitio
de internet muy grande este sitio
requiere de servidores web y servidores
para bases de datos cada servidor web
tiene un costo de 40 dólares por mes
mientras que cada servidor para base de
datos tiene un costo de 60 dólares por
mes
para tener una idea del costo mensual
total que pagará la compañía carlos hizo
la siguiente tabla aquí podemos ver en
la tabla la cantidad de servidores web
la cantidad de servidores para bases de
datos así como el costo mensual total él
calcula que si se necesita un servidor
web y éste tiene en cuenta un costo
mensual de 40 pues multiplicará 40 por 1
más la suma del costo de un servidor de
base de datos que 60 por la cantidad de
ellos 60 por 1 así lo podemos ver en
diferentes ejemplos tal vez aquí tres
servidores por 40 dólares 3 por 40 más
un servidor para base de datos que tiene
un costo mensual de 60 y así a nosotros
nos están pidiendo cuál es la expresión
que describe el costo total mensual para
n servidores web n serán los servidores
web
y ms servidores para base de datos
tomaremos m como la representante para
los servidores la cantidad de servidores
para base de datos que utilizaremos y
entonces nos preguntan la expresión para
el costo total mensual en dólares será
para ello lo que haremos es multiplicar
el costo que tenemos de los servidores
web que será 40 por n dado que estamos
tomando a n como la cantidad de
servidores web 40 n más
60 que es la constante que tenemos que
es el costo mensual por cada uno de los
servidores para bases de datos 60 por m
donde m significa la cantidad de
servidores para bases de datos que
estamos ocupando de tal manera que
nuestra expresión quedaría 40 n más 60 m
y para ello vamos a tomar el siguiente
ejemplo qué pasa si nosotros tenemos 20
servidores web pues 20 será n entonces
tomaremos 40 por 20 más 10 servidores
para bases de datos 60 por ms 60 por 10
que de hecho aquí lo tenemos 40 que es
el costo por n 20 en este caso más 60
que es el costo mensual por m/m en este
caso es 10 y con esto tendremos el costo
mensual total que pagará esta compañía
para tener funcionando adecuadamente su
sitio de internet